Analogy is often considered to be a core process of cognition. A common example
of analogy we encounter everyday is that of metaphors. For example, you can
imagine someone saying, I had to break up with her. We had grown very far apart.
Far apart here is a spatial metaphor. One of the famous examples
of metaphors comes from Shakespeare. All the world’s a stage, all the men and
women merely players. The theater here is a metaphor for
the world. A third connection is the Rubin’s test of intelligence.
The Rubin’s test is considered to be one of the most common and
reliable test of intelligence, and as you well know by now,
it is based entirely on analogies. An analogy is that central to cognition.